Okay.
I'm going to try
the only way I can check to make sure
I'm being heard is if you guys settle
in, right?
My wife used to teach first grade and
she gave me an a a suggestion cuz first
grade kids sometimes get out of control.
And she said the louder they speak, the
softer you should speak. I've never been
able to take her advice. Now, because um
so the first minute is always going to
be chaos in this class because it's a
big room.
But I want to first make sure you're in
the right class. It's the only class
that really matters.
That's my personal view now. Even my
valuation class is kind of an add-on.
I'll talk about why this might be the
only class you came back to business
school for
or should be. Now,
um
but this is my 32nd year teaching in
this room.
And I hate this room.
Plus, I mean, this is the ambiance of
Madison Square Garden on a bad Knicks
day, right? So, not exactly
a friendly room to be in.
And the acoustics stink. Stink in what
sense?
I think you guys can hear me. When the
architects built this room, they thought
about that. They said there's going to
be somebody at the front speaking
and everybody has to hear. You know what
they did not factor in? This is what
happens when you let architects build
classrooms.
That if you speak,
other people need to be able to hear.
And from that perspective, this room is
terrible. So, if there's a question from
this side, people on that side can't
hear.
So, I'm going to try and I'll keep
forgetting, so remind me when I forget,
that if there's a question, I have to
repeat it to make sure that it's in fact
going to be carried to the other side of
the room.
Now, since we're adding up years, now,
as I was coming up the elevator,
I ran into somebody who said,
"My mother was in your class."
I'm getting to a point where
grandparents are going to be on the
Now,
I've been teaching here since 1986. You
know, in a couple of years, they're
probably going to Next year, they'll
give me a pin or something, which I
throw away right away. The 40th year.
It's a Bible prices. Don't don't Don't
You know, I'm not that impressed. I've
managed to stay around, but that's not
saying much at a business school.
But, my very first class was in 1984
at the University of California,
Berkeley. It was an undergraduate class
that I remember the the the the
numerical code for the class, BA 130.
It was a corporate finance class. I was
terrified. I walked in.
And, to be quite honest, I didn't know
what corporate finance was when I walked
in, and I've tried to figure it out, and
I think I'm a little further along the
road than I was in 1984.
But, the core of the class essentially
goes back to where I started in 1984.
So, before we dive into corporate
finance, what it is, what we're going to
try to cover in the class, there are a
few logistical details.
First is, I do have an office. It's on
the ninth floor.
This building is really three different
buildings. So, there's Kmac, there's
Tisch,
So, it's in Kmac, which is the other
building. So, it's 969. And, as you well
know, these elevators don't talk to each
other. So, if you take the elevator in
the wrong building, God help you. You're
going to get lost. You'll never find.
So, take the elevators in the other
floor, 9-69.
My office hours, technically, are 12:00
to 1:15. I'll explain what I mean by
technically. 12:00 to 1:15, which is
right after the class.
So, it's a good time to come and ask
questions, but I am usually in my office
around 9:15 getting ready for class.
9:30 to 10:15, feel free to drop by,
especially if you have a quick question,
you want just want to say hi because
it's a big class, you really don't get
drop by. And I have a fair game
principle, which is if you find me, I'm
fair game.
Which means the game starts right now,
which is for the next 15 weeks, I'm
going to try to make it difficult for
you to find me.
No, I'm not going to try, but I'm going
to take the stairs rather than the
elevator. You know why? Cuz I know you
guys never take the stairs. Do they
still have those signs telling you
should take the stairs? I mean, for a
while they did. I think they took it
down because nobody was following it.
But truly, if you find me either in
person or virtually, I tend not to hang
out in the social media places you might
hang out. I don't live my life on
Twitter or Reddit.
I won't name the other places because I
won't embarrass you. No, definitely not
Tik Tok. No. But if you do find me
virtually, I'm fair game, too.
And
that means that it doesn't end after 15
weeks. You can hunt me down after 15
weeks, but then your grade is already
in.
So, the fair game principle applies.
I will also during my office hours turn
on my have I've set it up for Zoom. Why?
Because you know, I prefer that you come
in physically to for the office hours,
but in 2020, I started the process of
having just Zoom office hours. I
preserved that tradition because that
way we have a question and you're
working from home or you're you know,
which you shouldn't be. It's a Monday,
Wednesday right after class, but if you
get back home and you want to ask a
question, you're sick at home, you want
to ask a question.
No. The only thing is if there's
somebody in my office, they get first
dibs. So, if you're on Zoom, you might
have to wait a little bit, but I'll keep
the Zoom link on.
There are two teaching assistants for
the class.
Preston and Zoe. They both took the
class last year. They know how much I
torture you, so they're fully aware of
every piece of this class.
They will have office hours, but they'll
also have review sessions every week.
Now, during the review sessions, all
they will do is actually take problems
from past quizzes and exams and work
through that because I'm not going to
work through a single problem in class.
No, it's not what I enjoy doing. It's
not the best use of my time or your
time, but they will work through those
problems. So, if you feel you need that
additional help, take advantage of the
review sessions. So, more details will
follow on where the review sessions are
and when. Thank you.
Now, it's probably a little too late for
preseason prep, but I did send the email
out 2 weeks ago, right? And I know you
haven't been reading my emails, and this
might become part of a pattern, so I'll
act like you read my emails, and I'll
create a device where you have no excuse
for saying I didn't see that email.
But, I suggested that there are very few
things I will draw on in this class, but
three things I would like you to bring
in the class that'll make your life
easier
and mine, too.
The first is I will say some terrible
things about accountants, and I mean
every word of it.
But, let's face it, our raw data in
business comes from accounting.
Does that mean you have to know debit
and credit and accounting rules?
Frankly, I don't know debit and credit.
I couldn't care less about what
accountants call their rules, but you
have to be able to tell me the
difference between gross income,
operating income, and net income. If
you're still struggling with what's the
difference,
that's a signal that your accounting
didn't stick.
In In theory, you've all taken your
accounting class, right?
I said in theory. I don't know how much
of it stuck. Now, but if you feel it's
not stuck, and the way you'll know is
when you open up a financial statement
and you really get lost right away.
Right after the revenue, everything else
is some mysterious No.
Uh if that's the case, I've created my
own version of an accounting class,
which would make an accounting professor
blanch, because I break every accounting
rule. It's the accounting that I need
for this class.
So, if you feel shaky on accounting and
you want to revisit that class, it's 12
sessions. It's about 3 and 1/2 hours all
together. It might be an investment
worth making.
Second skill set
is statistics. If you've taken a
statistics class, at least in theory
again,
the tragedy of statistics classes is you
forget them almost immediately after you
finish Thank God that class is over. I
will never need it again.
Okay? The old days when you had books,
you could sell them back to the
bookstore. This was the first book you
sold back.
Okay? And that's almost tragic because
if you think about what we face, not
just as finance people, but as human
beings, we're inundated
with I won't even call the day with with
data, right? Information.
We're we're facing information overload.
And the problem with that is you're
getting pulled in different directions.
You say, "How do I break the tie? I have
five different things that claim to tell
the truth, but they're all telling the
Statistics is designed for big and
contradictory data.
So, for not even for this class, in
general,
I think it's a good idea to revisit
statistics and say, "What can I take
from the class?" And you might take only
20% of the class to use to make sense of
that data around me.
So, in corporate finance, you're going
to have a lot of data coming at you. In
fact, I will argue that your biggest
complaint is not going to be I can't
find enough information. It's going to
be I'm finding too much information,
and it's pulling me in different
directions.
So, here again, if you feel your
statistics class did not stick,
I've created 12 session version of a
statistics class again from the
perspective of somebody who's not a
statistics person at heart, but somebody
needs statistics in finance, in in
valuation, wherever I run into it. So,
if that's your weakest link, fix it.
And finally,
how many of you taking foundations
simultaneously?
Okay, few. It's not It's not a pre-req
for this class, but there are a couple
of tools out of the foundations class
that we'll draw on.
First, of course,
time value of money.
If you're still struggling with what
present value is intuitively, I know you
got the PV button worked out in your
calculator or your computer, but you're
still not quite sure what it means,
you got to get that out of the way,
right? Because finance is almost
entirely time value of money.
So, if you feel that those very basic
finance pieces are shaky, I have a
minimalist foundations class
looking at instruments and time value
that you will lose in the class. So,
if it's too late for pre-season prep
right now, but if at any stage you find
that these are the things that are
impeding
your progress in this class, you're
you're getting stuff in this class, go
back and revisit them.
I will torture you.
Every day, and this is a promise, not a
threat,
every day from today till May 5th, which
is your last day of class, and probably
spilling over 3 days after that, you
will get an email from me.
Not a text message, I know, so I will
stay with emails.
And every day the email will cover
something different. So, right after
class today,
there will be an email about what we did
in class today. So, I wasn't in class
already. I know physically you were
here, but sometimes you can take a
mental break.
And when that happens, you come back
from that mental break, you say, "What
the heck happened?" This email might
say, "This is what happened, right?" So,
it's not like
a Twilight Zone episode. This is where
we are.
On Tuesday,
which is tomorrow, you'll get what's
called the corporate finance puzzle of
the week.
It won't start this week because we
won't have done enough, but starting
next Tuesday, every week
I'll put out a puzzle. You're saying,
"What scary thing is that?" It's going
to be something topical.
For instance, I might say,
"What's the big business news that's
come out over this weekend?"
Deep Seek, right?
I mean, today the market is entirely
structured around Deep Seek. So, next
week my question might be, "If you're in
corporate finance working for Nvidia
or working for Microsoft, how does the
entry of Deep Seek change your core
business story?"
So, it'll be something general where you
can use the tools of corporate finance
to at least start answering the
question. Something that's in news of
the week that we're building around.
Again, structured around what we're
doing in class.
On Wednesday, again, there'll be an
email after class telling you what there
is and
essentially following up on the class.
And on Thursday, I will send out an
email about your project. You're saying,
"What project?" In a few minutes, I will
describe
what you're going to be doing through
the course of this class. Your project
is already started. You just don't know
it yet.
We'll talk about how this project plays
out, and every Thursday I will try to
guilt-trip you.
Why? Because I know exactly what's going
to happen. The project is actually not
due till May 5th.
I will nag you about staying on course
with the project, but I know exactly
what's going to happen, which is
you're going to ignore my nagging,
you're going to fall behind, and the
12th week you're going to say, "I have
to pick a company?" Yeah, you were
supposed to do it 12 weeks ago.
So, think of this as a guilt trip. I
say, "This is where you're supposed to
be on the project." I'll let you fill in
the gap as to where you actually are and
what to do to cover that gap.
On Friday,
I'll do what's called an in practice
webcast. Sounds fancy, but I will take
something that we do in class that say,
"Go get that." And you say, "Where the
heck do I get that?" This will take you
the process. So, for instance, we'll
talk about risk-free rates in a couple
of weeks.
How do you get a risk-free rate in
Indonesian rupiah? We'll go through this
in class,
but then you'll say, "Where did he get
the data? How did he build it up?" The
webcast will take you through those the
grunt work of collecting the data so you
can estimate rate in Vietnamese dong or
Indonesian rupiah
or Brazilian real.
On Saturday, there will be a newsletter.
What news? Not much news, but basically
to tell you this is what we did last
week. You'll notice a lot of revisiting.
Part of the reason for that is in a big
class, you can get lost, especially as
you get to the middle of the middle of
the semester and things get busy.
Think of this as a GPS. I say, "This is
where we are in the class. This is the
page we are in the lecture notes." So,
the newsletter is really about grounding
you in where we are in the class. So, if
you get lost, you can say, "Okay, I can
see where I need to get."
On Sunday, there'll be a newsletter
saying, "This is what's coming in the
next week." So, you're ready for the
classes for the week. So, this process
will play out. I have the tendency to
send really long emails. I
would say I'm sorry, but I really am
not.
So, I'll act like I'm sorry, but I'm not
because in the emails I'll throw in
things that I've been reading saying,
"Hey, you know, think about this in the
context of what we talked about in the
class today."
Now, in terms of class rules, there are
very few.
I'd like you to be here.
You think, "Where else would I be?" I
will make it easy for you to not be
here.
And then I will ask you to be here. In
what sense? Every session is going to
have a Zoom link and be recorded.
That way, you have no excuse for missing
the class. You can be in whatever part
of the world. You'll have to get over
the time difference, but you can watch
the class. If you can't watch it live,
you can watch the recording.
And some of you will be tempted around
the second or third week cuz you're
sleeping in. You think, "Sleeping in at
10:30?" Hey, my you know,
people are capable of sleeping in
till 2:00. My son, yes, I was supposed
to meet my son for brunch yesterday.
We had brunch at 3:00.
I said, "Call me when you wake up."
Now, he's now is out there what you
know, but basically, you know, whatever
he does on Saturday night clearly spills
well over into Sunday morning.
But he called me at 2:00 saying, "Dad, I
just woke up." I said, "Okay."
I kind of planned for this. Brunch
becomes brinner, brinner becomes dinner.
God only knows what meal you're eating,
but it doesn't really matter.
So, if you will be tempted at points in
time saying, "Do I really want to put my
clothes on?
Can I stay in my pajamas all day?
Maybe I can just do this." I would like
you to be here.
Obviously, it's better to be here on
time.
But if you can make it 30 minutes late,
I'd rather have you here 30 minutes late
than not at all, but if you cannot make
it,
you're sick, God's sake, don't come in
with COVID or the plague or into the
class. I don't want you here physically
sick. Stay at home to watch it.
But if you cannot make it, you'll be
able to keep up with the class.
All you need to bring to the class is
the lecture note packet. And of course,
if you have an iPad or a or a regular
computer, you can download the digital
version. I'm not going to cause the
rainforest in Brazil to shrink because I
want to teach this class. If you feel
you need a physical copy, by all means
print out the packet. Just don't do it
on the printers downstairs cuz then I
will hear about it cuz you print what?
450 pages and times 250 people, you'll
kill the printers and then they'll
reach out to me and I'd prefer that not
happen. Um so if you have if you if you
if you have work if you're working
somewhere part-time, print off their
printers. I don't care, right? Ruin
their printers.
So
if you do miss a class, catch up on the
class. Don't let it go too far behind.
I know there's a Brightspace.
I never use it. I get on there because
I'm supposed to and they harass me if I
don't.
And then it just sits out there.
I don't like closed learning systems. I
didn't like what preceded. This is the
fifth or sixth learning system that NYU
has used. I've ignored all of them.
Brightspace will have its uses because
the grades will obviously be easiest to
check there. So you will see your
recorded grades. If you forget what you
got in a quiz, you can go go look it up
there.
But almost everything that happens in
this class will happen through the
webpage for the class. And that link is
right there. I've sent it a couple
couple of times. So think of that as the
platform for all of the material for the
class.
There is a YouTube channel that will
carry
the the lectures.
It'll also carry all the in practice
videos. So basically it's there. What is
that for? While you're taking this
class, I think this semester that I
10,535
people will also be taking the class
unofficially
for no credit and no payment, you know.
But they'll be watching just the YouTube
videos on there and
they won't No, obviously they won't be
dropping in on office hours or, you
know, hacking the Zoom session in live,
but the YouTube channel basically will
have all of the sessions.
Remember I talked about an email every
day? You will at some point in time
probably block me.
Why? Because I'm, you know, killing your
mailbox.
And then you will, when I talk about
remember that email I sent last week,
you're going to say, "What email?"
I'm going to take that excuse away as
well because every email that I send you
will go into what I call the email
chronicles, which is going to be
classified by date. This is the email.
So, you You have no excuse for saying,
"I didn't see that email." It's there in
the chronicles. So, if you don't check
your emails, because that's not what you
do, the chronicles will carry it.
Few more logistical details. The class
is obviously on Google calendars, so you
can see when the quizzes are. There is
zero flexibility in terms of moving quiz
dates. I'll talk about what will happen
if you have to miss a quiz, which I
understand can happen.
Part of the reason I have
250 people, I can't afford to have too
many moving pieces. Things start to blow
up on me. So, the Google calendar will
tell you. I think the final exam date is
finally out, so I'll put that up as
well, you know, but that's
going to list out the dates for the
class.
No, I do have this blog where
I dabble. I dabble in things that
interest me. So, it's really about me.
I'll write about whatever interests me.
And maybe some of the things that
interest me will interest you as well.
You've seen the first three data updates
I sent for this year. I sent the links.
If you get a chance, read them. You
don't have to be a finance person.
The first eight update basically is
about how I update the data. The second
is about what US equities did in 2024.
The third is about slicing and dicing
the equities, which sectors, which
industries, market cap, price to I mean
basically all the different ways you can
slice and dice.
But I know I am already pondering a
piece on deep seek and saying how does
deep seek change the value of companies?
Which companies are going to be most
directly impacted? Which are indirectly
impacted? What does this all mean for
that AI
hype,
hope, whatever you want to call it
that's been driving markets for the last
year.
I do have a Twitter feed.
And it's all about numbers for me.
I mean my end game in life is to always
have more people
on my social media platforms than my
kids collectively do. So I just you
know. So what I'm saying is if you have
four email addresses, put them all on
Twitter, and put them all down as
followers. I can take four over one
every single time. But you know, it's
basically I use Twitter not to have
online debates or discussions. I've
never ever responded to a tweet because
bad things happen when you do.
But it's my announcement device. It's
very effective at saying I just posted
or I just put the data up and then I
leave it alone. But if you want
on time announcements that something has
come up that's a new data item, this is
where you find it.
In terms of required material, the only
thing you need
is the lecture notes.
So you can if you feel that a book will
help, there's actually a book that
parallels this class. It's called
Applied Corporate Finance. It's a book
that's in that's in its fourth edition.
And basically everything you see will be
in there. So it's supplementary. You
don't need to use it because it's
obscenely overpriced. I would not buy my
own book.
And I can't in good conscience ask you
to buy the book.
But if you feel wealthy, I don't know
what that means. All
how you feel wealthy with the tuition we
charge you, I don't know. But if you do
still feel wealthy and you have excess
cash,
then by all means buy the book.
Practice prompts,
there will be practice prompts in every
exam and quiz I've ever given in a
corporate finance class, which goes back
I think to 1986 is online.
You So, there's you want practice
quizzes, you'll have more practice
quizzes than you ever wanted to see.
This is actually a curse, not a
blessing, and you will see very quickly
what I mean by that as you start
approaching quizzes. But every exam and
quiz I've ever given is online, you can
find it.
And along the way, you know, whenever
you use a model or data, you're going to
see it online as well. So, logistically,
the class is structured to be almost
a class you can take sitting in your
bedroom and never leaving it.
So, if you have some strange
mental problem, you cannot leave your
room, you can still finish this class.
Let's talk about this class.
What is corporate finance?
Anybody want to give that a try?
Before I jump in with my definition.
Let me back up. How many of you have
taken, I should have done this right out
the stop, an undergraduate corporate
finance class?
Okay.
How many of you are finance people? You
worked in
in some kind of a finance job. It could
be banking, it could be consulting, it
could be in a corporate finance. How
many of you are finance people?
I want the everybody in this class to
look around. This is not 1986.
In 1986, if I'd asked that question
or even in 1995,
the vast proportion of this class, at
least its turn would have been
bankers coming back for rehab.
Right? I mean, basically, you spent 2
years in banking, you came back. This
was like a conduit. So, this class would
have been recovering bankers coming back
to say, "I really don't want to recover,
but they kicked me out anyway." Right?
This is a very, very diverse class. Many
of you have not just not worked in
finance. This might be the very first
finance class you're taking.
But, among the people who took corporate
And it also means that you cannot Don't
use the excuse of I'm not a finance
person. I'm not going to let you get
away with that excuse in this class. I
will make you a finance person by the
end of this class. I'm a bit of a tele-
televangelist on this dimension.
My idea of this class succeeding is at
the end you say, "I see the light. I'm
no longer a marketing person." I'd say,
"Thank you, God."
And
But, if you've taken a corporate finance
class, you should be able to answer the
question. And you got an entire class
with this title.
What is corporate finance?
Anybody want to try?
Come on, I'll make you look good even if
you give me the wrong answer. I'll
reframe it to make it the right answer.
I'm very good at that.
You said you'd taken a corporate finance
class, right? Did somebody You took a
corporate finance class?
Okay. One of the problems with this
room, and I apologize for this, is
there's no place to put your name
plates.
Okay? And it's awkward for everybody to
say, "I am so-and-so." So, if I say you,
it's not because I No, I don't see you.
It's because I really can't see your
name. So, I'm
What's your name?
Jose, what what exactly do you think
corporate finance is?
Interpretation.
Is it just an interpretation though? You
sound I mean we sound like psychics
then, right?
It has to be more than it has to be not
something that covers the actions of a
company you said?
That's interesting. What kinds of
actions are we talking about?
All the actions, not just the financial
actions.
Because people I mean the reason I ask
this question is at least in New York,
the definition of corporate finance gets
really cramped.
Because it's set by what investment
banks call corporate finance.
What do investment banks call corporate
finance? Usually the interaction between
firms and financial markets. That's what
investment banks come in, right? Which
is are you raising capital? Are you
doing a deal?
Calling that corporate finance is like a
podiatrist claiming to be a general
practitioner.
You're looking at toes all day.
You're
really
no position to tell me what the rest of
me looks like. It's a very narrow vision
of corporate finance. So, I'm going to
give you my definition of corporate
finance. It's incredibly self-serving.
I asked you how many of you are in
finance? You know what? Every one of you
has been in finance. You just didn't
know it.
Corporate finance covers any decision
made by a business that involves the use
of money.
You're in marketing?
You think the company spend money on
marketing?
You're in HR?
You don't think my people money gets
spent? If you spend money, it's a
corporate finance decision.
You see how incredibly self-serving this
is?
You know, do they do they still have
that orientation when for first year
MBAs where they make you come in a week
before class starts there? and then they
try to tell you that everything you know
is worth nothing and that the next 2
years is what matters. It's complete
brainwashing.
And I've never really wanted to be
involved in that process because you
make false promises that you know you
can't deliver. But about 7 or 8 years
ago they made the mistake of inviting me
to talk to the orientation class. Why?
Because this has become a rite of
passage for Stern MBAs. This is an
elective and for some reason it's an
elective that draws a big chunk of the
first year MBA class.
They said, "Can you come in and talk to
these entering MBAs about what your
class is about?"
So I went in with a chart and I don't
think they've ever they're ever going to
invite me back again. I said, "This is
what the MBA program looks like. There's
my class
and there's all these other classes
you're going to be taking that are in
service of my class. They just don't
know it yet."
I'm going to argue that everything you
do is going to feed into my corporate
finance class.
Your strategy class is going to lay out
the foundations for my forecasting what
the future is going to be in terms of
revenues and margins and cash flows.
Your marketing class, your accounting
class, every class in a sense is a piece
of this class.
So whatever you choose to do, this class
is going to follow you around and
perhaps haunt you.
It is every single thing in a business
is corporate finance.
So I lay out the objectives for the
class and then I'll try to use the rest
of this class to flesh out the
objectives. If you ask me to describe
this class,
first,
it's a class that is applied. What does
that mean?
When I first start taught corporate
finance, I was given a syllabus to
teach. The syllabus, of course, like
every discipline includes all the things
that are supposed to be taught in the
class.
And the first semester I taught it, I
had no choice.
I taught the syllabus that was
essentially corporate finance syllabus
in every single class with a textbook
that went with it.
And then I started
asking the question, why do I need to
know this? Or why does somebody in this
class need to know?
So, I started applying a very simple
rule that started to prune my syllabus.
I said, if it cannot be applied,
I don't care.
And if I don't care, why should
everybody else care? So, I went through
the syllabus taking out things that were
supposed to be there that I could see no
way of applying in the real world.
What's left in this class? With the
version of the class you see is my
version of corporate finance, which is
about, hey,
if I can't apply it, I can't use it.
Everything in this class is going to be
applied. I'm going to peripherally again
reference your project. You're saying,
what's the project going to be about?
You're going to pick a company and
everything we do in this class,
everything, you're going to apply on
that company.
And if you can't apply it, I'd like to
know because I'm going to take it out of
the class if it cannot be applied.
Second, this is a big picture class. By
now, even after your first semester, you
probably become a little cynical about
the word big picture because every class
claims claims to be a big picture class.
I'm going to show you the big picture on
the next page of corporate finance, and
I'm going to stay true to that big
picture. Everything we do in this class
is somewhere in that big picture.
Third,
and this is going to sound a little
sick,
I think corporate finance is fun.
It allows pieces to fit together. What
I'm looking for are what I call the aha
moments in this class where something
connects for you.
Where something you've never been able
to quite understand. Why is Nvidia worth
4.3 trillion?
Or why do companies buy back stock? Are
buybacks a good thing or a bad thing?
Maybe some at some point in this class
you will at least start to get the
pieces of understanding why companies do
what they do
and why they sometimes do stupid things.
So, I've laid the the objectives. In the
very last session, I'm going to come
back and revisit those to see if I've
delivered. So, on May 5th, you'll see
that same page pop up with a very
different ending. Is did we did we get
get that done?
So, let's start
by first getting you out of what I call
the accounting mindset.
Now, to the degree that accounting class
at least partially stuck,
I'm going to take you through an
accountant's favorite financial
statement.
Only accountants love this statement,
but I'll we'll talk about why.
And as I go through this, you're going
to get a little perspective on how
accountants think about the world and
why you need to snap out of it.
If you're an accountant, my condolences.
You spent a lifetime getting Yes, I'll
have to slap you. It's more In fact, I
have more work with in this class than
getting the class through to accountants
than any other subgroup. And you're
going to see why.
Let's take an the accountant's favorite
financial statement. If you step back,
there are three core financial
statements, right? Anybody want name
them?
Go ahead.
Exactly. Income statement. And tell me
at least in broad terms what each is
supposed to do. What's the income
statement supposed to do?
Or made made. Don't not made because
it's always backward looking, right?
Made. So, it tells you how much the
company earned, which is which is a big
deal.
What is the statement of cash flows
telling me?
How So, basically, it's like looking at
the checkbook. How much cash came in?
How much cash went out? What's left? And
what's the accounting end game with a
balance sheet?
What you own and what you owe, right?
That's basically what each is supposed
to do. Let's not dress these up as most
more glorious than what they're supposed
to be.
So, at least in theory, a balance sheet
is supposed to show what a company owns,
what it owes. And you say, "What about
the difference?"
That's what your equity is supposed to
be worth as a business.
Let's go through an accounting balance
sheet because along the way you're going
to see the inconsistencies
that have built up in accounting as we
know it.
And why the accounting balance sheet has
less and less
value
in it.
And I'm using the word value
deliberately here.
So, let's see how much of your
accounting stuff. If you look at
accounting balance sheet, broadly
speaking, there are four classes of
assets.
You have long-lived physical assets,
land, building, equipment, machinery.
Accountants are big on tangible versus
intangible. We'll see why that is, but
if you can see it, it's now.
If you have long-lived physical assets
like factories and equipment,
and you see a number in an accounting
balance sheet. I'll stay with you. How
do accountants come up with that number?
Let's take a, you know, plant or
equipment.
Somebody want to help Mark with physical
real assets, what is the rule in much of
the world still?
It's what you paid. Mark-to-market has
not made migrated there, right? So, it's
what you originally paid for something,
but that's not the number you see. So,
what's happened to it while it sat
there? It's been Why at least
accountants say it'll probably get less
worth valuable over time. So, it's what
you originally paid. Already you can see
the first problem here, right? If I
bought a building in New York City in
and I see the building on my balance
sheet, what's going to be true about the
number you see there?
It's going to be completely disconnected
from reality.
But it's accounting. Stay with the
accounting mindset. We'll snap out of it
because it's very dangerous to stay
there too long.
That's physical asset land, building,
equipment, machinery.
Then you got short-lived assets. What
are those? Inventory, receivables.
Usually under the current assets column.
Here, it's still what you originally
paid for it, but it's usually not that
different from the current value. Why?
Cuz hopefully your inventory hasn't been
sitting on your in your storeroom since
1965.
In which case you're probably done as a
company. It's probably 6 months old. So
here it's still what you paid for it,
but it's closer
to current value.
Then you've got investments in other
companies. And here accountants are all
all over the place.
Let's take Microsoft. What's its most
high-profile investment in another
business?
OpenAI. They've invested $14 billion in
OpenAI.
So if I went to the Microsoft and
at least till Friday, OpenAI was
presumably worth a lot of money. And
we'll talk about what's happened since.
But if I went to Microsoft's balance
sheet, what what am I going to see as
the value of OpenAI?
That $14 billion that they invested. It
could go to 100 billion, 200 billion,
but it doesn't get marked to market
because it's classified as a strategic
investment that Microsoft did this. And
it's true, right? They built did this
because they want to build OpenAI into
their products. So if If have a
cross-holding in another company or
another business or an asset, and it's
to help your core business,
it'll be recorded at what you originally
paid for it.
And the disconnect from reality there
can be immense.
I remember valuing Yahoo in 2014.
In 2014, what was Yahoo's business?
A search engine that nobody searched on.
And then a mail program that I think
only people over the age of 75 had even
heard about Yahoo Mail.
So, I valued the business being as
generous as I could. I came up with the
value of 4 billion. The stock was
trading at 39 billion. You say, "That is
weird."
You know what explained the difference?
It was actually not a You know, it was
not overvalued.
What What did Yahoo own that wasn't
caught in the 4 billion?
They owned pieces of two companies.
One was a company called Yahoo Japan.
That's a stand-alone publicly traded
company. But, for some reason the
Japanese still like Yahoo search
engines. Don't ask me why. So, it's
worth It was worth about at that time
Now, 35% was worth about 10 billion
dollars.
And the other was a 21% holding in a
Chinese company called
Wrong Chinese company. Try again. You're
very close. Alibaba.
You know how they got the 21%? They were
a venture capital investor in Alibaba,
and they invested about a billion
dollars. Best thing Yahoo ever did,
right?
Cuz by 2014, Alibaba was on the verge of
going public. And if you remember, it
went public at 200 billion. What's 21%
of 200 billion?
It's not a trick question. It's 40
billion plus.
If you looked at Yahoo's balance sheet,
that Alibaba holding was recorded
at less than a half a billion. You say,
"That is weird." That's what they
originally invested
as a VC. So, with cross-holdings, you
can see that some cross-holdings are
going to bear no resemblance. But, if
you open up a SoftBank and you look at
its holdings in I won't say WeWork,
that's too much of an open wound to pick
at.
But, you look at its holdings of
Alibaba, which is
and SoftBank is also a big investor in
Alibaba.
What are you going to see?
Because SoftBank is a VC company, it
viewed as a trade It's viewed as holding
its investment for trading.
It has to mark to market.
You're saying, "This is a mess." I
agree.
So, when you look at a financial balance
sheet and you look at holdings in other
companies, you might have to dig through
the footnotes to see what those
recordings are because it could be
marked to market, it might be recorded
original cost, it might be
you know, adjusted for book value. It
could be all over the place. When
accountants claim to be consistent,
they're lying. Call them out.
There's no consistency in this process.
And then you get to intangible assets.
Let's start with a generic question that
has nothing to do with accounting or
finance.
Are there companies out there that get
the bulk of their value from things you
can't see?
Take the seven largest companies in the
world. They're the Mag 7, right?
What's Apple's
biggest
asset?
It's not the physical plants.
It is
It's everything, right? The operating
system, the styling. Remember their Jony
Ive, legendary stylist. This is a
company that actually thought about
styling. So, when you look at your
iPhone, you're seeing the results of
tens of millions of dollars. Should the
edges be,
you know, curved or should they
You're saying that is such a waste. They
clearly don't think so. Intangible
assets.
What's Google's biggest intangible
asset?
Again, not that stupid campus they've
built on in California that's a
playground.
It's a search box that we still go to
when we want to find things whether we
trust it or not.
You take the mag seven.
Maybe Tesla might have some physical
assets that Fremont plant in the in the
plant you know the three other four
other plants they've added on.
But for all of these companies the bulk
of the value comes from things you
cannot see intangibles. So let's start
with an acceptance.
You look at the big companies of the
21st century most of their value comes
from things you cannot see intangibles.
So you know what the last 30 years
accountants have been wrestling with how
to bring intangibles on.
The amount of time and energy they've
spent trying it's called fair value
accounting which is an oxymoron.
Cuz you can either do value or
accounting but they keep trying. The end
game is you want to bring in intangible
and it's a what they mention right?
And given how much time they've spent
and how much they talk about it you
think they must have done a pretty good
job by now.
So the end of 2024 I took every balance
sheet in the world it's easy to do now
the data is there capital IQ can
download the balance sheet. I added up
the intangible assets on all accounting
balance sheets. Big number.
It's gone up a lot over the last 20
years you think great accountants are
finally catching up.
But here's the problem 85% of all those
intangible assets still come from one
item.
Now that one item is
it's the most destructive accounting
item ever created it's called
goodwill.
And here's why I call it the most
destructive. I mean if you worked at
KPMG or Ernst & Young this was your
mother's milk in terms of how your
business ran right? Cuz you You called
to assess goodwill and then every year
you're called into impair that goodwill.
This is like a continuing business model
for you.
I'm cutting at the heart of your entire
existence, and I'm going to do it
anyway.
Here's why it's the most destructive and
meaningless asset of all time.
For goodwill to manifest itself on a an
accounting balance sheet,
what does a company have to do?
Buy another company. So, already you can
see the basis for the problem. If you're
the greatest company in the face of the
earth, but you've grown entirely with
organic investments,
there will be no goodwill on your
balance sheet.
Take a look at Apple's balance sheet.
You know how much goodwill there is?
Almost nothing.
Why?
What was the last big acquisition that
Apple did?
Beats. That was like petty cash.
This company has never done a big
acquisition.
If you don't do a big acquisition,
there's no goodwill.
Conversely, if I go out and acquire a
company, let's play a game. So, let's
say you go out and acquire a company for
$10 billion,
right? How do I measure goodwill? What
is it that it has to be the difference
between two numbers? What is it that
What are the two numbers that that I use
to get goodwill?
What you paid is a purchase price. Let's
see how much accounting brainwashing
you've gone through. What's the other
number? So, the purchase price is
observable.
What's the other number I compare it to?
Let's keep the liabilities out, but
let's at least, you know, it's But,
what number would I put to those assets?
If you've taken an accounting class,
you're told it's a fair value of those
assets. There's nothing fair or value
about it. I live in the value domain. To
call that fair value is, I think, an
insult to both words.
It's a counting book value dressed up.
So, here's what happens. After you do an
acquisition, a team from Ernst & Young
shows up at your offices. What do they
do? They do a 3-month elaborate Kabuki
dance. You watch this, you that. And
after 3 months, they say, "We've done an
assessment of your assets, and
it looked like the value that you had 3
billion is wrong. It should really be
3.13 billion." They'll add more decimals
to show that they've done a lot of work
in the 3 months.
But, it's book value dressed up.
Dressing a book value is like dressing
up a turkey.
It's tough to hide that scrawny neck.
Right?
But, you dress up book value, come up
with this number. You got a $10 billion
purchase price, you got a $4 billion
dressed up book value.
As an accountant, you got a $6 billion
problem, right? To explain away why.
Because until yesterday, you were
telling me the company was worth four
Oops, it's worth 10 billion.
So, what do you do? You take that $6
billion difference,
and you put it on the balance sheet,
and you call it goodwill. And why do you
need to put in the balance sheet?
Cuz balance sheets have this very
unpleasant requirement, which is they
have to
balance. Why does goodwill exist? To
make balance sheets but it's a plug
variable.
You'd be amazed how often I get emails
from people saying, "I have a company
with $5 billion in goodwill. How much
should I pay for it?" To which my
response is a plug variable. What the
heck are you paying for?
Every year I do send suggestions to the
accounting rule writers, which they
never seem to take.
So, about a decade ago, I sent a
suggestion that we rename goodwill.
In algebra, when you have two numbers
that don't equate, what do you do? You
say, "Plus X." You can make any two
numbers equal to each other. I said,
"Let's call goodwill X."
If you open an accounting balance, you
see goodwill, it sounds good, right? It
sounds like there's stuff behind it.
Let's just call it X. That way you'll
never feel the urge to pay for it.
Already you can see that when you look
at the accounting balance sheet for a
company.
And from that you extract the value of
equity in a company because when you
look at the shareholders equity on a
balance sheet, the classic book value of
equity.
You know what you're getting? You're
getting a reflection of the company's
entire history. It's the ultimate
backward-looking number.
So you took Coca-Cola and you look at
its shareholders equity, it includes the
capital raised by Coca-Cola at its IPO.
When was that? I have no idea, but it
was a long, long, long time ago.
Plus
retained earnings every year. If you're
writing it mathematically, that's what
shareholders equity is. It's the
ultimate backward-looking number.
When you first look at a company, that's
what you see, right? The accounting
balance sheet. And already you can see
why with the rise of companies like
Apple and Google and Nvidia and Tesla,
accounting balance sheets
are losing their value.
They're losing value because you're
really learning nothing about a company
by looking at its accounting balance
sheet.
So here's what I'm going to ask you to
do. When you look at your company,
you're going to see an accounting
balance sheet. So this assumes you've
picked a company looking at the
accounting balance sheet.
I want you to in your mind start
thinking about what I call a financial
balance sheet. And at one level it's far
simpler than an accounting balance
sheet. And at another level it's far
more complex.
You look at the asset side of the
balance sheet, there are only two items,
right?
I don't divide the world into tangible
and intangible, fixed and non-fixed. I
divide into things you've already done
as a company and things I expect you to
do in the future.
Things you've already done in the past
I'm going to call assets in place,
investments you've already made. I'm
going to put a value on them. Could they
have a big value? Yes.
For a company like Coca-Cola, what's in
there?
The original soda you created, syrup,
the etc., etc., all the beverages you
acquired, all the geographies, you know.
That's assets in place.
The second item looks kind of
mysterious, growth assets. That's a
value I'm attaching to things I expect
you to do in the future. Things you
might not even have thought about yet.
I'm giving you a value. You say, "Why
would I do that?" We do it all the time.
Talked about Nvidia, 4.3 trillion. How
much of that 4.3 trillion is for things
they've already done?
On a good day,
maybe half a trillion.
I'm
You say, "What about the other 3.8
trillion?" Scary as it might be,
this is what you're building in for
things you expect them to do. Where?
That magical AI space, right? People
have to buy chips, and those chips are
going to come from Nvidia. And how are
you going to run AI without those chips?
And on Friday evening, we attached a
value of 3.8 trillion and went to sleep.
You slept through the entire weekend.
You wake up on Monday morning.
There's a lot of sleep deficit to
overcome.
What's changed?
What did What does deep sync do? It
basically tries to do many of the things
that AI people claim you could not do
with powerful chips, with data that AI
people said you need a lot more data.
What's going to happen to the 3.8
trillion? You're going to reassess,
right? The value of growth assets could
go down, go up, things are going to
happen. The nature of growth assets
based on expectations of future, and
those expectations can change.
It's dynamic.
It's going to be different for different
companies. What about Coca-Cola's growth
assets?
There's not much there, right?
What are you going to do?
Where are you going to go? You're
already in every part of the world.
Your beverage has kind of hit saturation
point, and if anything, you could argue
that maybe it's going to get less
valuable over time. Maybe the sugar
problem finally up with them.
For Coca-Cola, the bulk of the value
comes from investment they've already
made. So, one of the things to do when
you look at your company, I don't care
what company you pick, is look at where
the value of your company comes from.
You haven't put a number yet, but at
least get a sense.
Am I looking at a company where the bulk
of the value comes from the future? Am I
looking at a company
where the bulk of the value comes from
the past? Doesn't make one company good
and the other company bad, but it'll
give you a very different set of
corporate finance choices as you move
along.
And in this financial balance sheet,
what do you see as equity? It's not a
historical number, it's always a
forward-looking number.
Could you be a company that invested a
hundred billion dollars in the past and
you're worth nothing now?
Sure.
I was reading about this company called
Constellation Energy.
It's I don't know, it's zoomed in the
last couple of years. Why? Because it's
been building these very large because
AI chips and the story until Friday was
you need powerful chips, you need these
these these centers, data centers, that
require immense amounts of power.
And there's an ecosystem that's been
built around. We supply the power to
these AI
I wouldn't be surprised Constellation
lost some half of its value today.
Doesn't mean the market is crazy, it
just means that expectations can shift.
The value of equity in a financial
balance sheet is a forward-looking
number and it can change at the drop of
a hat.
So, I promised you the big picture, let
me deliver. I'll tell you up front, if
you get this page,
the rest of the class is icing on the
cake.
This is the only page that matters
because it covers every core first
principle in finance,
and let's lay it out.
I told you corporate finance is about
any decision that a business makes that
involves the use of money, right? But
I'm going to classify those decisions
into three buckets. You can have
investment decisions.
What are investment decisions? Projects
you take, acquisitions you make, even
deciding whether to put a water cooler
in your is a is an investment decision.
And the first principle in corporate
finance is when you make investment
decisions,
make sure you earn a return on those
investments
that exceeds some minimum acceptable
hurdle rate. That sounds like a
buzzword, right? So, for the moment I'm
not going to fill in the details, but
I'll give you the sub principle that
governs how we think about hurdle rates.
I know most of you might not be finance
people, but tell me whether this at
least makes common sense is is common
sense. The hurdle rate should be higher
for riskier investments
than for safer investments. Everybody
agree with that?
Now, I haven't told you how much higher.
We still have a lot of work to do. We
have So, and it should also reflect
where you raised the capital. Did you
borrow the money or use your own money?
So, the minimum acceptable hurdle rate
should reflect the riskiness of the
investment and how you raise money to
fund that investment.
You're saying, "How do I measure
returns?" In corporate finance, returns
should be based on cash flows.
Already, let's pause there.
As opposed to what?
What is the entire accounting class's
bottom line?
What is the bottom line in an income
statement?
It's earnings. I'm saying, "Look,
returns shouldn't be based on earnings."
Why? Because you can't spend earnings.
That sounds mysterious. We'll come back
and talk about it. Cash in, cash out.
Cash flows should reflect the timing of
the cash flows.
Would you rather get, you know,
I'm going to ask Would you rather get
cash flows earlier or later?
Somewhere I mean, this is something we
knew. I mean, I with each of my kids,
they're all grown up now, the age of
four or five, we I had this test to
figure out whether to put aside money
for college.
And this is usually right after they
started getting their allowance. And
usually they get their allowance on
Saturday, and I would call each of them
in in different points in time, and they
say, "Would you rather wait till
Saturday to get your allowance, or would
you rather get it today, which is
Monday?"
And you know, the answer I didn't want
to hear, they said, "I'll wait till
Saturday." I'll say, "Do you know what?
I'll take your college fund. Let's
figure out something practical for you
to do. You're not going" Thank God my
first three kids all said, "No, I'll
take it today."
My fourth kid I knew I said I had extra
money aside because here's what he
asked. He said, "Is it the same
allowance, Dad?"
Yes, time value of money, right? You
wait till Saturday if I give you a
higher allowance. That's time value.
It's amazing how we dress this up and we
forget the basics as we go along. But
when you measure returns, those returns
should reflect not just how much you get
as cash flows, but when you get the cash
flows.
The timing.
And there should be no side effects
built in. There's no garnishing allowed
in investment analysis.
Say, "What are you talking about?" Many
of you worked in businesses where you
grind out numbers for an investment. You
You don't have to be a finance person.
You're looking at an investment, you
grind out the numbers, and the numbers
don't fly. You know what I mean by don't
fly? Investment doesn't look good.
And then somebody in the room
comes in with the garnishing. Like what?
There are strategic
reasons for this investment. Strategic
is the most dangerous word invented in
business.
Basically means the numbers don't fly,
but I really really really want to do
this.
There's an AI in this space somewhere.
We'll be in China. I You know, you These
are garnishing. You're throwing them in
after the numbers have been thrown in
saying,
"Hey, we want to take this project. Can
we find a good word to justify it.
Now, I'm not going to let you get by.
My job is to take the big words and
let's see what that means. I'm not going
to dismiss your strategic
considerations. I'm going to bring them
into the numbers.
Investment principle says, take
investments that earn a return greater
than your minimum acceptable hurdle
rate.
Of course, we have a lot of work to do.
Right? We have to measure risk and
convert to a hurdle rate. We have to
bring the mix of debt and equity, but
that's why we have 25 sessions left of
the class.
Let's turn to the financing principle.
The financing principle is two parts. I
said there were two ways you can raise
money. Debt or equity. Borrowed money or
your own money.
Which one should you use? I can't give
one answer that applies to all
companies, but here's what I can say.
Find the mix that minimizes your hurdle
rate.
You see the advantage? You'd rather have
a 9% hurdle rate than a 10 because it
lets you take more investments. It makes
your investments more valuable.
What will that mix be? Again, a lot of
work for us to do, but it definitely
will not be the same for every company.
And if you ask me what kind of debt
should I take, I'm going to turn the
question back on you and say, "Tell me
something about your assets. What do you
invest in?"
I know you haven't taken the class yet.
But I'm going to put to you on the spot
and you're going to be my co- Right, you
don't look back. I'm looking at you. As
I said, that's a problem. You have to
point here.
Okay? I could do the laser, but I could
blind you, so I know I'll I'll just let
this
You ready? So, you're going to be my
advisor. I am an infrastructure company
in Portugal.
What kind of debt should I take? First,
long term or short term?
And why did you say very long term?
Because I'm taking long-term projects.
And what currency should I take the debt
in?
So, if I build a toll road and I collect
tolls in euros, my debt
that was easy. I should use long-term
euro debt.
You know how much how many mistakes in
corporate finance come from taking
something simple and making it
complicated?
Okay?
The rule in corporate finance is when
you go out to borrow money, borrow money
in a way that the cash flows reflect the
assets you take. Are there cases where
you might have to make adjustments? Yes.
You might be having an infrastructure
project in Zimbabwe.
And you might be unable to raise money
in Zimbabwe because capital markets are
not developed. You might raise your
money in Europe or the US. You're going
to get a mismatch, but at least you're
aware there's a mismatch and you can do
something about it.
So, financing principle says go out and
borrow money
and get a mix that minimizes your hurdle
rate.
And match up your debt to your assets.
And then there comes the dividend
principle.
And people lose their minds on it.
If you cannot find investments that earn
your hurdle rate.
Let's say your hurdle rate is 9%. The
best you can do is make 7 and 1/2%.
I've heard managers say that's the best
I can do. No, that's not true. There is
another option, which is
what can a company do if it cannot find
investments that make its hurdle rate?
Give it back to the owners. You're a
private business, take it. There is no
glory in growth for the sake of growth,
in surviving for the sake of surviving,
or sustainability for the sake of
sustainability. I'm again, I'm going to
pick on sustainability and and other
glorious words we've got into the
business lexicon.
If your core reason for existence is
gone, just go away.
Trick.
It's a dividend decision.
If you're a public company, it gets a
little messier, right? You can't just
take cash out. You got to return the
cash and cash and you said you can pay
dividends. And until 1980 in the US,
that was the only way you got cash back.
But I'm as we go through this class,
you're going to see a trend that is well
beyond pushing back on, which is
increasingly What's the other way in
which companies give cash and return
cash?
They're buybacks.
So already you can see the place.
Buyback is just
a version of a cash return that is
different. We'll talk about why that
switch has happened, its pluses and
minuses.
But which one should you use depends on
what your shareholders prefer, right?
They're getting the cash.
If I am Google and I have a lot of cash,
which one do you think they'd prefer to
get the money in dividends or buybacks?
You think so?
You know, if you look at the I mean, how
many of you are investors in Alphabet? I
I call it Google still. Are shareholders
in Alphabet? You are a shareholder? Why
do you buy shares in Alphabet? Because
of the dividends you expected to collect
on the stock?
I wanted price appreciation. This is a
stock I had in that segment of my
portfolio where I said, "I want this
Which means the shareholders who
self-selected to invest in Google did it
because they wanted to get price
appreciation. They didn't In fact, I
don't want to get dividends. You know
why?
Cuz April 15th is coming up.
The minute I get dividends, I have to
pay taxes on it.
So if you're a
Google and you have lots of cash, you
But if you're Con Ed
or you are Citibank
and you have lot extra cash, you can't
then what should you do?
Who holds shares in Con Ed and City?
Probably No, I I don't want to make
sound agent but ages, but probably
either pension funds or 75-year-olds.
Right? People who want the cash.
I'm not saying it's a bad thing. They
could They buy these stocks for the
dividend.
There is no right answer. Should I pay
dividends or buybacks? Look at your
shareholder base. The answer is right
there.
And in doing all of this,
in corporate finance, we have a singular
objective.
I'm trying to maximize the value of the
business. That's a loaded objective. You
say, "Well, how the heck do I measure
value? What the heck is the business?"
That's the end game. And we'll talk
about that. But this is the big picture.
Everything in this class is tied to
something in that big picture.
So, I'm going to use that big picture to
bring home some core themes in corporate
finance
that are going to be pretty
straightforward. First is
much of corporate finance is common
sense. In fact, let's take the much out.
All of corporate finance is common
sense. Because think about it. Many of
you've never taken a finance class or a
corporate finance class.
Has any of the stuff that I've said so
far surprised you?
I mean,
what have I said? If you raise money at
9%, please please don't take investments
that make 8%. Yeah, I knew that already.
So, if you can raise money at 8% rather
than 9%, use the 8% You're saying, "I
knew that already."
And if nothing I look at can make even
that 8%, you know, take the money out of
the business. I knew that already. And
that shouldn't surprise you.
You know how old corporate finance is as
a discipline?
37 I'm sorry. 67 years old. Can trace it
back to a paper written in 1957
by Merton Miller and Franco Modigliani.
Until 1957, corporate finance was just a
glorified accounting class.
67 years old. How long have people been
running businesses?
Definitely more than 67 years.
Probably some very good cave business
people.
Their disruption was fire, Never seen it
before. This is the disruptive force.
Our tools extra sharp.
Right?
Good business people through It takes an
incredible ego on the part of corporate
finance people to say, "Until we came
along, you guys just were picking
business uh making these decisions
randomly."
Good business people through the ages
have always understood these first
principles.
That's why you can be a great business
person and not just not have an MBA, but
never have gone to school.
One of India's largest companies,
Reliance, was founded by Dhirubhai
Ambani, who was a fifth-grade dropout.
But an incredibly shrewd business
person.
You can him, right? You
couldn't try the garnishing with him and
say, "You know what? This investment
makes only 7%. Our cost of capital is
10, but that's okay. Strategic." He'd
have probably thrown you out of the
office.
Conversely, there are people out there
with MBAs and PhDs
who seem to have lost touch
with these first principles.
So, here's my suggestion. Whenever we do
something in this class that doesn't
connect with you in terms of common
sense,
I want you to push back. Even if you
don't feel If you feel too intimidated
push back in class,
come back and say, "I don't quite get
this."
Because I want you to make that common
sense connection. Not just as an
abstraction of this is the right thing
to do, but this is why it's the right
thing to do.
Second,
corporate finance is focused.
One of my problem any institution that
doesn't have a focus is you're all over
the place.
Right? In any given day, you're trying
to do something different.
It's nice we have focus. That focus
comes from the central objective, which
is maximizing the value of the business.
And in some case with publicly traded
firms, that gets narrowed down. We'll
talk about why to maximizing stock
prices.
You know why in corporate finance we
like that? Because it's observable.
When you make a decision, I can look at
the corporate the stock price affected.
Comes with consequences, but that focus
means everything we do in corporate
finance we can ask, "What's the right
way to do it?" Because we know what the
end game is. If you don't know what the
end game is,
how do you know what the right thing to
do is?
We'll talk about the pushback against
this particular end game. He said, "Why
maximize value? Why not maximize
revenues or growth?" We look at the
alternatives. But everything in
corporate finance is built around that
end game because it tells us how to pick
projects, how to fund them, how much to
pay in dividends.
But I think that every disagreement you
and I are going to have over the next 15
year weeks is not going to be about the
mechanics. It's about the end game.
So, when you disagree with something
corporate financial you say, "I don't
like buybacks."
Turns out that you might not like
buybacks because you think businesses
have should have a different end game.
I'm going to spend probably what you
think will be a disproportionate amount
of time on the end game in business. Why
we chose the objective we do. What are
the alternatives?
I'm going to say it's going to inoculate
you against all the critiques you're
going to hear about corporate finance in
your other classes.
Because
I think there are good arguments that
can be made, but I will look at the
counters to those arguments.
I have 12 books. My 12th book came out
in September of last year.
It's called the corporate life cycle.
What does it do? It argues that
businesses go through a life cycle just
like you and I do.
And businesses behave just like human
beings behave.
I'm not going to be mysterious. A
startup is like a baby.
Needs constant care and attention and
lots of capital.
With a huge mortality rate.
Why? Because two-thirds of startups
don't make it
to the toddler phase.
You're a toddler company, you fall, you
get up, you sometimes fall and don't get
up.
You're staggering, your business model
is shaky. Again, huge mortality rate.
Let's say you make it to your teenagers.
What do you do near teenagers? What
teenagers around the world do?
I had four go through my house and
here's what each of them did. They'd
wake up in the morning, look in the
mirror and say, "I have lots of
potential.
What can I do today to screw it all up?"
That's a teenage mindset. Complaining
about it doesn't make a difference
because that's a teenage mindset. When I
bought Tesla in 2019,
I bought it because it was undervalued,
but the post I wrote about why I bought
it, I titled it my corporate teenager.
You know why? Because it has lots of
potential, but every morning one man
gets up. He looks in the mirror and
says, "What can I do today
to screw it all up?"
I buy the package.
You take Elon Musk with all his
dimensions when you buy it, good and
bad. It's part of the package. You make
it through your corporate teenagers,
you're at the peak of your life. Enjoy
it while it lasts.
What does the peak of your life look
like as a human being? It's when you can
go to bed at 3:00, wake up at 6:00, and
be a fully functioning human being. I
don't even try that at Think about
trying that today.
Enjoy the peak of your life because
everything you touch turns to gold.
Nvidia
until Friday again
was at the peak of its life.
What happened over the weekend?
I mean, what's what my daughter has been
not looking forward to this last year is
she turns 30
in April and she's convinced the world
is going to end.
You know why? Cuz after 30 comes middle
age.
It's such a doom-filled word, right?
You're going to be middle-aged. Who Who
amongst us says, "I want to be
middle-aged one day?"
But it's coming, right?
And what happens to middle-aged
companies? They've got to act like
middle-aged people.
Don't overexert yourself.
You might have a midlife crisis and buy
a Ferrari.
A company might have a midlife crisis
and do a big acquisition, but guess
what? A Ferrari doesn't make you 25
again. For a brief moment, you had that
dream, but it doesn't last.
But enjoy middle age.
Because after middle age comes even
worse stuff.
Like old age and then after old age
comes dementia. After dementia comes you
pass away. And companies go through the
cycle.
When you pick your company, one of the
things I'd like you to think about where
in this life cycle is my company.
Let's try this. No. Where do you think
Apple is? Let's let's try this. Where do
you think, you know, OpenAI is?
In this.
It's probably like a baby, but I'm not
sure whether it's Damian from You know,
it's it's like a baby, but you're very
terrifying baby, right? It could be a
have all these No. Daddy, there's no
business model here. It's It's a baby
with very strange powers and you're not
sure what'll happen next, right?
What about Palantir? Where do you think
you'd put it? What does Palantir do?
Mysterious things
with the CIA and the FBI are afraid to
ask what it does because you might end
up in Guantanamo Bay.
It's clearly a company with, you know, a
young company, perhaps approaching the
peak of its life.
Nvidia we talked about in the peak of
its life, but that might pass. Every
other one of I mean if you look at most
of the other mag seven,
you look at Alphabet, you look at Meta,
they're middle-aged. They're at a good
middle-age. They've kept themselves in
shape. Middle-age is not always a
That's what I tell my daughter as well.
It's not the end of the world. You can
be Alphabet type middle-age or you can
be Kraft Heinz type of middle-age.
Right? What does Kraft Heinz do? 57
types of ketchup, all of which taste
like crap.
And cheese that stays liquid for the
rest of eternity. It's a terrifying
thought, right?
But for a while people loved it, but now
its customer base is 65 and older. It's
probably
old age, and that old age comes with its
own consequences.
A couple of years ago I valued Bed Bath
& Beyond. Where would I put Bed Bath &
Beyond in the life cycle? All you have
to do is walk into a Bed Bath & Beyond,
and you know,
and this is before they shut down. This
is not long for the world.
We're not even sure what do you sell.
It's a terrifying retail concept, right?
You walk in Bed Bath & Beyond. I
actually looked at the beyond first.
There's bed and bath, I kind of get it.
What is the beyond? Whatever they want?
All right.
And for a while it was a
concept that caught on. I know lived in
New Jersey for a long time. I no longer
do for lots of different reasons.
But I lived a few miles away from the
Bed Bath first Bed Bath, and and it took
off until
it got to a point people didn't go in
there.
Two years ago I valued Bed Bath &
Beyond. It was like valuing a corpse.
There's nothing there. There's no real
end game here.
And there's nothing wrong with that.
Business is a If you tell me where
you're in the life cycle, I'll tell you
which part, which principle you should
be focused on.
If you are Palantir, what are you
focused on? Primarily, the investment
principle.
How much can you borrow? Are you kidding
me? You're losing money. What the heck
are you doing borrowing money?
First rule in holes is stop digging if
you're in one.
How much should you pay in dividends?
Absurd. You can't be paying dividends.
As you age as a company, all of those
principles will start to evolve.
I'm going to talk about the life cycle
often on this class because it's amazing
how much of what you see in a company
can be explained by where it is in the
life cycle.
And when it gets dysfunctional, it's
because a company is refusing to act its
age.
Right?
Intel throwing
billions of dollars into the foundry
business because they wanted to be like
TSMC or billions into AI because they
wanted to be like Nvidia.
Company overreaching, trying to be
something that they cannot be.
And fourth, corporate finance
is universal. In fact, it's unfortunate
that there's a word corporate in the
title, right? Because what does that
lead you to think? What we're going to
talk about applies to companies.
It's not true. This is something that
applies to all businesses, small or
large, public or private, developed or
emerging market. I have never felt the
need to write an emerging market
corporate finance book or a corporate
finance book for doctors or corporate
finance I mean, there is really it's
corporate finance of first principles
apply. Are there estimation differences?
Obviously.
We're going to talk about how a private
business's hurdle rate might be
different from a public company's hurdle
rate. How an emerging market company, an
Argentine company, because of the
constraints it faces, might have to kind
of alter the way it but the principles
don't change.
Which brings me to the final theme,
which is if you violate these first
principles,
somebody will pay. Maybe not you, but
somebody will pay.
I I about people with MBAs and PhDs
sometimes thinking the first principles
don't apply to them.
And then they act in accordance. It
always ends up catching up with them or
somebody else. Let me give you an
example.
It's an Indonesian taxi cab company in
the 1990s called Steady Safe.
I'm sure none of you have heard of this
company. It's no longer around as and
the story will tell you why.
So in night early 1990s Indonesia's
booming
Steady Safe decides it's going to expand
which means what? Going out and buying
more taxi cabs. You put on.
So you're going to be my banker.
You want to be my banker?
This case Steady Safe had a bank called
Paragon but you're going to be my banker
and I'm going to ask you some very
simple question about funding this
expansion.
I'm going to borrow money to buy taxi
cabs.
And?
What type of debt should I take?
You're not allowed to ask me back
questions. So
ask me the question you need to know the
answer to decide on the terms of the
debt.
With in this case cabs, how long do the
cabs last? Right? Let's say I tell you
10 years and then run them into the
ground. The debt should be 10-year debt.
What currency?
Rupiah.
Indonesian rupiah. A 10-year Indonesian
rupiah debt. That was a no-brainer.
Let's play out what actually happened.
Steady Safe went to an investment bank.
Investment bank called Paragon. A bank
that's no longer in existence either.
And they asked them this question and
they were told take 10-year debt.
But in US dollars.
And they were given a very alluring
reason. What do you think that reason
was?
It's cheaper to borrow money in US
dollars than in Indonesian rupiah. Very
dangerous word to use cheaper. It is
lower. The rate is lower. We'll talk
about why that with they said it's
cheaper.
And Paragon Steady Safe listened to
them. They went out and borrowed the
money in US dollars. They fund this
growth and then
to give Paragon to give Steady Safe
credit they went to Paragon and said,
"Should we be worried about the fact
that we're borrowing in dollars to fund
these rupiah assets?"
And the investment bank said, "Don't
worry about it. The Indonesian
government has pegged the exchange rate
and promised us that nothing bad will
happen."
Famous last words because in the mid-90s
the Indonesian government devalues the
rupiah by 65%.
So, let's wake up to the morning after
it's Steady Safe.
What's happened to your assets? They're
all rupiah assets. In dollar terms
they're worth 35% of what they were
yesterday, right? If your debt had also
been rupiah debt, it too would have been
marked down. You wouldn't have been
happy, but you'd have been okay. You'd
have survived. But their debt is in
dollars, their assets are in rupiahs, so
guess what happened to Steady Safe?
They went bankrupt and the only good
thing that happened is they took their
investment bank down with them.
It happens far too infrequently if you
ask me because they're always there at
the wedding, they're never there at the
divorce.
Actually, they have two teams, a wedding
lawyer and a divorce
basically they make money on both sides.
But just because Goldman tells you to do
something that violates first principles
doesn't mean that you're going to get
away with it or McKinsey.
And I'm astonished sometimes at the
advice that comes out of these places
and I said, "That doesn't make any
corporate finance sense."
So, the entire as I said structured
around that big picture so you'll see
rather than a traditional syllabi, we're
going to start with starting next
session. But
much of the session going through
session four we're going to talk about
that objective. Why did we pick that end
game? What are the alternatives? And
along the way we're going to talk about
things like sustainability and ESG and
stakeholder wealth maximization that I'm
sure you've seen rise up to the surface
in other classes and why we don't go
down those roads.
Then, we're going to spend about, you
know, eight sessions talking about
hurdle rates, measuring risk, bringing
to hurdle rates.
Three sessions on returns.
Followed up by a financing mix,
dividend policy, and then we're going to
go back to value and become more
explicit about how do all these
decisions tie into that.
So, I will see you on Wednesday, and get
ready for an email, a really long email
that will come exactly at 12:30.